just one bite from a venomous snake
could kill you
but
what about
drinking venom straight out of a glass
cheers
what is snake venom made of
how would swallowing it be different
from being bitten
and
how long would it take to kill you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you drank snake venom
when a venomous snake sinks its fangs
into you
a complex mixture of toxic proteins
enzymes and other molecular substances
is injected straight into your
bloodstream
this is to disable you and break down
your cells and tissues so that you're
easier to digest one bite often leads to
paralysis internal bleeding
and death
it's not pretty
snake bites kill 81 to
138 000 people worldwide every year
so
would one sip of snake venom
be your last
if you were bitten by a poisonous snake
the venom would travel from the fangs
into your bloodstream within seconds
you'd have a low chance of survival
how it goes down depends on the type of
venom but let me get back to that in a
moment
snake bites can be dangerous but if you
decided to drink the venom the story
would take a different turn
snake venom is not the same as poison
the protein-based toxins of snake venom
need to get into your bloodstream to
cause substantial damage
if you swallowed it your stomach acids
and digestive enzymes would likely break
it down
it could be like you never took a sip
wait put that snake down i didn't say it
would be completely safe
drinking a shot of venom might not give
you the same painful results as pouring
it on your open wound but it wouldn't be
harmless
some could still make its way through
your digestive system and into your
bloodstream
if it did
you'd experience something called
coagulopathy
it's a condition where the blood's
ability to clot is impaired
from there it could go wrong very
quickly
remember how i said there were different
types of snake venom
yeah if you ingested neurotoxic venom
from a cobra or a mamba and your stomach
acid didn't break it all down
this venom would start to block or over
stimulate your nervous system
this could lead to reduced eye movement
droopy eyelids and difficulty talking
swallowing and breathing
based on the neurotoxic effects of
taipan snake venom you'd be living
through this venomous hell for 5 to 10
hours
it could take weeks for your nerves to
repair and it would leave you unable to
breathe without external support
if you drank enough of this venom to
disrupt the chemical signals sent
between your neurons
it would leave you paralyzed
it could even kill you
now if you decided to take a sip of
rattlesnake or copperhead juice
you'd be ingesting hemotoxic venom
if this venom made it into your
bloodstream it would primarily impact
your blood and heart this could lead to
serious internal bleeding or it could
cause blood cells to lump together
causing blockages and heart failure
this type of venom can be found in
snakes like vipers rattlesnakes and more
mycotoxins present in this type of venom
could significantly damage your muscle
cells or cause necrosis
you'd be going through a painful
experience as the membranes of your
muscle cells dissolved
to make things worse the venom proteins
would leak into the urine and cause
long-term damage to your kidneys
your heart would lose its normal rhythm
the increased levels of potassium in
your blood could cause your heart to
stop
finally if cytotoxic venom from your
cobra spiced drink got into your
bloodstream
it would cause the premature death of
cells in your tissues
parts of your tissues could become
liquefied
cobras are a common example of snakes
with cytotoxic venom
these are all devastating effects that
venom could have on your body but
ingesting venom could also play a role
in developing human-derived antivenoms
yeah rock and roll musician steve ludwig
has been ingesting deadly snake venom in
various ways for over 30 years
he started this to see if he could
become immune
and after years of drinking this stuff
his body developed an anti-venom
anti-venom typically comes from horse
blood
some snake bite victims die because
their bodies reject it so a human
derived option is important
if you're into dangerous cocktails
remember the development of antivenom is
expensive and not a priority for many
pharmaceutical companies
drinking venom
simply wouldn't be worth the risk
now maybe you could take a dip in a pool
full of snake venom instead
well
that's a story
for another
what if